brain fête des pères c'était beaucoup
trop agressif comme entrée aujourd'hui
c'est le jour des explications c'est
aussi le jour de la fête des pères c'est
aussi un dimanche je vais donc vous
expliquer un tour que vous allez pouvoir
faire à votre perte pour la fête des
pères mais ce matin en me réveillant
j'ai une idée particulière je vous
propose un tour interactif entre votre
père et moi par votre intermédiaire je
vais donc commencer par vous apprendre
le tour comme ça vous allez pouvoir le
faire à votre père pour faire le tour je
voulais un petit pdf dans le descriptif
de la vidéo que vous pouvez télécharger
et comme finalité du tout en fait de
voir votre père soit mon dernier snap
soit mon dernier tweet soit mon dernier
message sur facebook que ce soit sur la
fanpage joue sur le profil ou encore sur
instagram pour tous les réseaux sociaux
vous les avez aussi dans le descriptif
de la vidéo
et c'est dans le message qu'il ira que
le tour prendra tout son sens par contre
si jamais vous préférez que je lui fasse
le tour moi même je vais vous le faire
en vidéo vous si vous préférez le faire
votre père vous même ce qui serait
beaucoup mieux
vous aurez juste à répéter ce que j'ai
fait dans la vidéo mais si jamais vous
n'osez pas le faire vous avez juste à
lui faire voir la vidéo
à partir du moment où je vais clapet
avec le youtube clap
je pense que tout ça est clair et
limpide pour commencer vous devez
demander à votre père de prendre un
papier un crayon et vous préparez votre
téléphone en mode calculatrice vous
allez voir c'est plus pratique
bonne fête des pères première bonjour à
vous votre papa je m'appelle fabien
olicard je suis mentaliste
et oui votre fils ou votre fille passe
beaucoup de temps apparemment à regarder
mes vidéos et on a préparé quelque chose
ensemble pour essayer de vous mentaliser
comme ça à travers l'écran vous devez
absolument avoir près de vous un papier
un crayon et peut-être un téléphone
portable en fonction calculatrice ça
vous servira après je vais vous demander
de penser et même d'écrire un nombre à
quatre chiffres ça peut être n'importe
quelle suite de call chiffres ça peut
être votre code secret de carte bleue et
ne croyez pas que vos enfants ne le
connaissent pas ça peut être votre date
de naissance a peut être les quatre
derniers chiffres de votre numéro de
téléphone peu importe vous écrivez un
nombre à quatre chiffres
une fois que vous l'avez écrit vous vous
concentrez sur ces quelques chiffres et
vous allez les mélanger dans votre tête
dans l'ordre que vous voulez ça vous
donne un nouveau nombre à quatre
chiffres
et vous allez l'écrire juste en dessous
exemple concret j'avais écrit 3787 je
pourrais écrire en dessous 7837 ce sont
les mêmes chiffres mais mis dans un
ordre différent vous maîtrisez tout
c'est vous qui prenait toutes les
décisions je vous laisse faire un tout
petit peu ça doit être bon c'est bon
plus que deux étapes et on va faire un
petit retour dans le passé
vous allez maintenant soustraire le plus
grand nombre par le plus petit nombre
c'est pas nécessairement le premier par
le deuxième ou le deuxième par
et dans mon exemple je ferais 7837 -
3787 je me marre parce que je me dis
s'il ya une personne en france qui a
choisi le même numéro de moi ça doit
être hyper flippant de l'autre côté de
l'écran ça vous donne donc un nouveau
résultat qui est issu de votre choix de
départ des quatre chiffres et de votre
manière de mélanger c'est vous qui avait
décidé tout ça et pour créer votre
nombre final on va faire un petit peu de
numérologie votre enfant connaît bien la
numérologie peut vous aider vous allez
simplement additionner tous les chiffres
du résultat de votre addition ensemble
par exemple si je devais faire de la
numérologie sur ce résultat là je fais
trois +14 +48 + 5 13 fait ce petit
calcul et vous avez un résultat
maintenant peut-être le vôtre c'est rien
que le vôtre vous pouvez l'écrire si
vous avez peur de l'oublier c'est avec
celui ci qu'on va jouer en retournant un
tout petit peu dans le passé à une
époque où il n'y avait pas de vidéo sur
les téléphones pourquoi parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de smartphone pourquoi
parce que vous avez connues et j'ai
connu je vous rassure les téléphones à
cadran
on avait ça quand on devait composer
tous les numéros surtout quand cité
souvent dans l'es9 et qu'on se planter
dans le dernier et qu'on était obligé de
tout refaire depuis le départ j'ai connu
ça on a eu un téléphone à touches que
tardivement chez moi aussi moment
nostalgique vous remets à cadran à
l'ancienne juste ici et voici ce que
vous allez faire vous allez compter avec
votre doigt en faisant le nombre de
cercles qu'il faudra autant de fois que
le nombre final que vous avez eue après
la numérologie vous allez donc poser
votre doigt sur le 1 en comptant 1
ensuite sur le 2 ans comptons 2 3 3 etc
etc et vous vous arrêterez forcément sur
une touche particulière la vôtre celle
qui correspond à votre nombre
numérologie cas était issue d'une
soustraction entre des chiffres que vous
avez choisi au départ convient du sens
pour vous et des soustractions est un
mélange de chiffres qui a été votre
choix aussi
je vous laisse faire allez-y faites le
et comme on va pas attendre tout le
temps mettez pose pour le faire on sera
plus tranquille et on reprend juste
après voilà vous êtes arrêté sur une des
cases du téléphone vous avez donc un
nombre en tête et aussi trois lettres
les trois lettres associer tous demandé
juste de retenir le nombre et les trois
lettres associés et maintenant je laisse
la place à votre fils ou votre fille
wanda qui vous fait le tour qui va vous
emmener sur l'un de mes réseaux où j'ai
mis un petit message à votre attention
j'espère que ce petit moment qu'on vous
organisé avec votre enfant vous a plus
passé une très bonne fête des pères
attention fin du tour voilà comme je
vous l ai dit je vous mets à pdf dans le
descriptif où je reprends en quelques
mots les étapes que vous devez suivre
pour faire le tour est également le
cadran vous pouvez imprimer tout ça est
comme ça vous lui faites à votre père
aujourd'hui et vous avez bien compris
que si vous
t'es pas de le faire vous-même vous lui
faites voir la vidéo ensuite voulu
l'emmener sur mes réseaux sociaux
n'importe lequel ya tous les liens dans
le descriptif également comme tous les
jours et puis voilà on aura fait un truc
ensemble pour la fête des pères je
trouve ça cool
par contre si jamais vous regardez cette
vidéo après le 19 juin sachez que pour
voir la finalité du tour vous allez sur
n'importe lequel de mes réseaux sociaux
et vous allez voir le poste de 19 juin
j'en mettrais qu'un seul ce sera
celui-là
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
alors oui aujourd'hui je porte un
t-shirt rigolo parce qu'il fait beaucoup
trop froid on et 19 juin et je me gèle
donc j'ai mis un pull n'hésitez pas à
laisser un petit commentaire daté vidéo
je les lis tous tout le temps et j'aime
bien vous lire vraiment si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo vous pouvez la
gratifier d'un magnifique pouce en l'air
d'ici là passez un excellent dimanche
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de
partir parce que le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao